alors frédéric on entend plusieurs
termes immigrants économiques réfugiés
clarifier pour nous quelles sont les
grandes catégories d'immigrants qui sont
acceptés d'abord ces dunes c'est
l'immigration économique c'est la plus
importante elle représente à peu près 58
% des demandes qui sont acceptés dans
cette catégorie on va retrouver les
travailleurs qualifiés qui sont
évidemment très recherché ici au québec
ensuite vous avez les travailleurs
autonomes ceux qui sont capables de se
créer un emploi lorsqu'ils arrivent ici
et ensuite vous avez des entrepreneurs
ainsi que les investisseurs qui doivent
remplir certaines conditions par exemple
apporter une certaine somme d'argent à
investir également dans des projets
économiques ensuite ça c'est à peu près
trente et une mine père trente mille
personnes en fait qui font leur demande
sous ce terme là on si vous avez
regroupement familial mais ça ça permet
en fait de profiter du programme de
parrainage de proches donc ce sont des
familles qui habitent ici qui sont soit
résident permanent ou citoyens canadiens
qu'ils peuvent faire venir des gens de
chez eux dans leur famille ils doivent
évidemment subvenir aux besoins de ces
personnes là et s'engager pour une
certaine période de temps ça c'est à peu
près un total de onze mille sept cents
personnes par année qui arrive ici au
québec ensuite vous avez des réfugiés et
les personnes en situation semblable
c'est à dire que ils sont pris en charge
par l'état par l'état ou alors ils font
partie d'un programme de parrainage
collectif ça peut être des associations
ou des organismes caritatifs qui veulent
faire revenir ces personnes ici et enfin
donc là vous avez neuf mille quatre
cents personnes et la dernière catégorie
on parle d autres cas assez particulier
plutôt rares motifs humanitaires quand
il y a urgence ou encore lorsqu'il ya un
intérêt public c'est des gens parfois
qu'ils n'ont pas de statut ou qu'il faut
réunifier ici alors on va adoucir un peu
les conditions encore vous savez c'est
juste 1000 personnes encore plus c'est
assez peu ça c'est marginal deux autres
chiffres pour terminer d'abord le québec
a en quelque sorte le contrôle sur 71 %
des demandes qui sont déposés ici donc
c'est la sélection du québec et le
nombre de personnes qui connaît le
français quand ils arrivent ici ses 41
points mais parallèlement à cette
immigration disons permanente là il ya
quand même ceux qui sont plus temporaire
voilà c'est ceux qui sont de passage
dans font ceux qui sont ici qui
répondent à des conditions particulières
pour avoir un permis de travail ou bien
un permis de séjour ou un visa en parle
ici évidemment des travailleurs
travailleurs saisonniers par exemple
pour les
les grosses compagnies agricole ou
encore bien sûr nous avons les élèves
internationaux les étudiants ici en tout
quand on regarde les chiffres au 31
décembre 2016
il y avait environ 99 puis une personne
qui avait un permis en règle
à ce moment là merci